okay welcome back to this video Dagan
Dagan let's see from Iceland right yep
iceland Mary the Kings in yet come on
move Bishop g7 almost yeah the sameish
variation yeah c5 is all the rage but if
I play that kind of a pawn down I really
don't know the theory of our of it so
I'm going with something else this 9075
is some kind of old-fashioned but not
terribly bad yeah I think I can go for a
bank or start setup here this particular
position it makes some sense with the
Queen od2 and the bishop only three tix
takes Bishop takes Bishop a 6 has night
see form in the mix maybe you should
actually take care with the night that's
more interesting ok I'm sure basics
anyway here here you cannot play with
FYI if I was hanging and Queen B 6 is
coming
soon
yeah sometimes you can play really
aggressively you with a queen bee six
takes then giving up the Queen for loop
takes a one but that's kind of that's a
bit much
is it an idea to play with this move
that that's really strange maybe because
of the unprotected State of the rook 27
rugby 84 Bishop takes ok is moving the
look now I can play c4 possibly this is
also why I didn't go Queen B 6 I wanted
the tech only five ok so i have in some
cases I have night takes a night d three
yeah Queen cannot stay only seven out of
the time how do i go here 97 f 493 now
that it's a this lettuce on yeah Queen a
5 or not not sure a knight ft 7 f for
this is really it's really not good 93
years probably not sufficient this is
compensation
ya have no clear idea here not not so
easy
I mean it's pretty clear that i have
some compensation for this pawn but if
it is enough that that's an entirely
entirely different matter okay Bishop
you an idea for you he didn't didn't see
that one right yeah Trix Trix Trix this
is why this opening is working at all 94
2292 Bishop takes ed for check and black
wins at least some material and that was
one line that I saw when I when the
Queen 85 of course a very cooperative
way to play okay so i can take c3 now
here the ruckus is hanging down on their
own be one so let's see how do I do that
g4 hangs to take here first or be one
first I don't know let's take here
and so I take now probably should like
okay what is this counterplay probably f
five years okay i can take a form yep
f4i now I thought Quincy to would be
good activating attacking the sea one
night yeah who patrols kind of soft
leading to much
hmm time please on these seven maybe I
don't know it's a tech t5 that Bishop
one a success is just badly placed
anyway now yes very little in terms of
activity rugby one Quincy to a some they
are limiting and whites options quite
quite clearly
yeah it's not very active but probably
what he had to do I'm informed oh I
didn't see that one what is occur what a
silly Oh was signed remarkable I was
just
check I was just thinking that I don't
know what I was thinking not much
probably okay so if I check here
I don't get it right just high angle
Zach just have given up the rook
there'll be one
16 seconds playing for rugby to
Jack check me that was a very bad game
of chess ow that was a very very bad
game with tons of blunders okay so this
this up to here I'm pretty okay with
what I did here I should just take d5
yeah that's much easier but ok this is
not exactly bad it is a winning position
so nothing terrible happening so I went
back here yeah I now wow this is just
remarkable I didn't I didn't I just was
just thinking okay he's covering this
but I didn't really hit didn't notice
that Bishop ephors in the in the game
any move basically that's not blundering
it is just winning but ok this is not
and now we took on g6 remarkably instead
of taking on b1 so our queen bee six is
a quick move here yeah just trading
Queens okay I had 20 seconds I had to
had to make moves here meh it is a draw
Queenie seizes the draw this is again
winning for black due to the better
better my nappies and the attacking
ideas with Ruby 2 and so on check down
yes to move the night of course
checkmate Jim I don't know I have to
have seconds so that that would have
been would have been tricky and oh maybe
this move it's not the best one bestest
Bishop before but that's
intending to get the depot rolling
that's very questionable if I would have
seen this idea probably not now it would
have been difficult with the time
position is I didn't have 3 2nd at 12
seconds so hard to say if I would have
would have made that so it was very very
nice that he actually allowed the direct
mate okay thanks for watching